وكانت قد خرجت مظاهرات نقابيه في باريس
ومدن عده احتجاجا على مشروع قانون لتعديل
نظام التقاعد وتزامن ذلك مع تعطيل لبعض
المرافق وهذا هو اليوم السابع من التحركات
المستمره منذ التاسع عشر من يناير كانون
ثاني الماضي ضد هذا التعديل بما يحمله من
رفع لسن التقاعد من اثنين وستين عاما الى
64 وجاءت مظاهرات امس السبت بعد اربعه
ايام من مظاهرات بلغ عدد المشاركين فيها
اكثر من ثلاثه ملايين شخص حسب ما قالت
النقابات
وقد طلب رؤساء النقابات العماليه في فرنسا
الرئيسه ايمانويل ماكرون باستشاره الشعب
بشان مشروع قانون اصلاح نظام التقاعد
وتمسكوا بالتصعيد
مارتينيز الامين العام للاتحاد العمل احد
اكبر النقابات الفرنسيه دعا الرئيس
الفرنسي لاستفتاء بشان تعديل قانون
التقاعد وقلم ارتناز ان على الرئيس
استشاره الشعب اذا كان واثقا من نفسه
واحترام رد الفرنسيين كما دعى رئيس
الكونفدراليه الديمقراطيه الفرنسيه للعمل
لوران بيرجي المسؤولين في بلاده بعدم
تجاهل الحركه الاجتماعيه الرافضه لقانون
التقاعد والذهاب لاستشاره المواطنين حول
المشروع
ساكون واضحا نقابتنا ستحترم دائما الشرعيه
والشرعيه هي التصويت في البرلمان لا
نستطيع القول ان ذلك غير قانوني فالامر لا
يتعلق بالشرعيه بقدر تعلقه بالانتجام
المجتمعي لبلدنا وهذا ما سنبحثه خلال
اجتماع تنسيقيه النقابات الاربعاء المقبل
ونشد الذين يديرون البلد عدم تجاهل هذه
الحركه الاجتماعيه
من امام مجلس النواب في باريس مراسلنا نور
الدين بوزيان انضم الينا نور الدين اذا
مجلس الشيوخ صوت على مشروع القانون ولكن
هناك مطالبات بالاستفتاء خاصه مطالبات
نقاط بيا استفتاء الشعب عليه ما فرص الذهب
لمثال هذا الاحتمال
مستبعده سلمى لسببين السبب الاول اولا ان
الرئيس اغلق الباب هو ثانيا في فرنسا هناك
مؤسسات من بينها مجلس النواب ومجلس النواب
ستعود اليه النسخه الرئيسيه لهذا المشروع
يوم الاربعاء
وقبل ذلك في الصباح ستعود الى مجلس الشيوخ
للمصادقه النهائيه الان الحكومه اخرجت
الاله الحسابيه لمعرفه من هو معها ومن هو
ضدها لكي تذهب اما الى خيار التصويت
بطريقه عاديه او الى فرض او استخدام
السلاح الدستوريه الاخر وهي ماده تحمل رقم
اربعه تسعه والفقره الثالثه والتي تقضي
باقرار وتبني وتزكيه هذا المشروع من دون
التصويت المشكله ان بعض الاحزاب وخاصه
المعارضه اليساريه بدات تهدد بانها ستعتمد
او ستقترح سحب الثقه من الحكومه يوم
الخميس المقبل هذا قرار باستخدام هذه
الماده الدستوريه لم يتخذ ربما سيتخذ في
اجتماع مجلس الوزراء يوم الاربعاء او في
اجتماع طارئ للحكومه يوم الخميس يوم
الخميس هو الموعد لطرح هذا المشروع بشكل
نهائي هنا خلفي امام مجلس النواب على كل
حال يمكن القول بان الحكومه سعيده في غايه
الفرح اليوم بدليل ان رئيس الوزراء غردت
وقالت بان هذه المرحله في اشاره الى
التصويت مجلس الشيوخ مرحله حاسمه من اجل
اقرار نظام كما قالت
سيحافظ على التقاعد في فرنسا ولكن في
المقابل هناك اصوات اخرى بدات تتحدث عن
احتمال ان يحدث او يحدث هذا القرار قرار
تجاهل الشارع وتجاهل ايضا المعارضه في
مناقشه هذا المشروع ان يحدث تصعيدا وتوترا
وتطرفا واضحا وهذا الذي اشار اليه مثلا
احد المسؤولين النقابيين عندما قال اذا
لجات الحكومه مثلا الخميس القادم الى هذا
السلاح الدستوري فذلك سيعود سيعتبر عدم
احترام للشارع وربما يفتح الابواب على كل
الاحتمالات بما في ذلك استخدام العنف
العنف في انتظار ذلك كان لافتا صباح اليوم
سلمى ان احد المسؤولين النقابيين قال بعد
قرار مجلس الشيوخ اعتماد وتزكيه هذا
المشروع سنساعده وسنعمم طبعا الاضرابات
السؤال الكبير لا احد يعرف لحد الان كيف
ستكون الكتابه النهائيه لهذا السيناريو
وعلينا ان ننتظر قادم الايام ومن الان
يمكن القول بان الاسبوع المقبل سيكون
حاسما بالنسبه لماكرون لحكومته وايضا
للمعارضه شكرا لك نور الدين مراسلنا امام
باريس